[Musique]
alfred veut acheter une auto neuve mais
n'a pas vraiment les moyens
il demande à sa mère de le cautionner
elle devient donc responsable du
paiement si son fils ne paie plus après
quelques mois alfred constate que ses
mensualités sont trop élevés là une idée
modifier son contrat d'assurance il a
sur le dos uniquement pour sa
responsabilité civile et enlève
l'assurance de dommages et ils n'en
parlent pas à sa mère peu de temps après
ce qui devait arriver arriva 8000
dollars de dommages et aucune assurance
sa mère n'en revient pas personne ne l'a
informé que son fils a changé son
assurance l'assureur devait-il informé
la maire d'alfred du changement de
police non parce que son nom ne figure
pas sur le contrat d'assurance
le fin mot de l'histoire si vous vous
porter caution
faites en sorte que l'assurance soit
aussi à votre nom